Oh my God!
So what are we getting?
We're getting ice.
We're getting...the most obvious choice.
Kill the engine, brother.
If you're really quiet,
and you listen through the waves.
You hear all the pops
and cracks?
Mm hmm.
This is the glacier ice expansion,
pressed snow and air bubbles
over thousands of years.
So when it melts, all
the air bubbles pop.
So if you put this in a glass
and you pour a cocktail on top of it,
you're going to get the same
popping effect.
I did not know glacier
ice pops and fizzes.
Like, even just now.
Just hold it. Just.
Just take a second, everyone.
Like, seriously?
It's magnificent.
I'm finding myself at a loss for words.
[Bleep]
No, no way.
We're surrounded
by walruses.
I can stare at
this all day, but let's collect
some of the glacier ice.
Oh, yeah, because
we actually have stuff to do.
We actually do have stuff
to do and a dinner to be prepared.
Here we go.
Maybe that one.
Let’s see.
[Bleep]
Only 10% of the ice is actually above
water.
It's all connected. Bye.
So these pieces are a lot bigger than they
appear on the surface.
Hold on. I got you.
Are you sure you have me?
Oh, damn.
One cubic foot of ice actually weighs
55 pounds.
Okay, so we're definitely going
to get our workout today.
[Bleep] That's heavy.
I'm going to taste it.
Cheers. Cheers.
Hmm. Salty.
It is salty.
But don't worry,
that saltiness won't be noticeable
in a cocktail since the ice itself
is made from freshwater.
and we'll be chipping these giant chunks
into very small pieces. Hmm.
I'll bet there's walrus pee on this,
what do you say?
A little bit of extra flavoring.